[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht dr
sie beruft wolle aber dank des 4 1 8
und dann wird die welt reisen mein gott
wie naiv ständigen zu einer anderen für
der welt müssen die ganze wände an dem
internet sie maximale kontakt mit allen
personen ab brauchen kann zu mir ist
klar dass das goldrichtig
[Musik]
zg
islam
[Musik]
si
die kalorien
berlin
[Musik]
für die bohrung ec karten weg
dementsprechend riesig so ist wie sie
ist vor ihrem bleiben bis auf anderen
die von der welt gefunkt und neuseeland
das größte verdienste von neuseeland
da am strand emr abgemacht
[Musik]
wo man sieht auch finde dass das einzig
weiß ich ziehe ich bloß in ihrem
apartment in los angeles eine irgendwo
der musiker sei am strand
das war schon mal gelohnt aber kreis
hinter wie das sind sie mir ich bin
irgendwie verstehst du schweizerdeutsch
wir verstehen paar bruchstücke ich lebte
eine weile in der schweiz und so
verstehe ich ein wenig ich weiß wenn man
über mich redet wo habt ihr euch das
erste mal getroffen
es war in indonesien vom strand
und ja ich bin auf welt 30 schon fast 5
minute und der eigentlich auf dem weg
auch noch sechs monate wider so der
harmonika und in den handflächen
verlängert katja ich noch mit schweiz
trug bei ihrem studium abschließen sind
2014 auckland zyklone zwei autostunden
von auckland weg direkt am meer
james m
[Musik]
neuseeländer sind die mia schmidt stolz
wir in die natur und landschaft und sie
sind der sportbegeisterung
mit katja und making of the whos berg wo
mount maunganui
[Musik]
wir sind ja ähnlich groß ist gegensätze
ziehen sich an
wir sind ungeduldig und bis 100
erstmalig zum erzählen dass ich nicht so
viel war vielleicht habe ich wie so dass
sie da will ich mir nicht so groß
überlegt mir einfach mal trainieren
also das ist der grösste gerade buchs da
weißt du so einen riesenschritt machen
so ja und ich habe ja wenn man so jung
ist denn ich muss sowieso tendenziell
etwas gibt es vielleicht dass die
genannten nicht gehen aber und wählt hat
armin ich brauche in der identität oder
rente von innere identität ja darum ist
mir wichtig dass die schweizer steht vor
s baujahr hat sich ein schatten über das
glück von der junge familienvater von
katja ich plötzlich gestorben
sieht ein tag ist katja ihre sehnsucht
nach der schweiz grösser familie und
will ich nur ein bisschen happig
gestorben
drum und freunde
wer die ganze in die mental oben
das jahrbuch vor allem weil ich so gerne
sähe hält und also eher groß sind und
wie so viele fotografen und data
verstaut oder er weiß dass ich sie sind
nagel deutsch als sich ali k
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
typische nerven
es sei
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
regitz und die kinderlosigkeit wo sie
sich im internet kennengelernt und beide
sind die nachhinein überzeugt das ist
genau so hätte sie 2011 sind schweizerin
und der stolzen akut davon gibt ich find
sie lernte verhaltenstrainer und ich
hüte aus lastwagen fahrer unterwegs
[Musik]
training
am anfang hat und immer wieder
sprachliche barrieren überwinden
aber im alltag und bewohner von der nada
hat sie sich sehr schnell
zurechtgefunden und wohl gefühlt
das tricksen auftrag von ihm schwanger
nachdem opfer sind ich habe mir das auf
dem internet mit youtube-videos anderswo
geht
lorca wenig die muss machen ja das
könnte zudem auch wenn du das wenn es
das familie teammitglieds weiterkommt
und zeigt aber es macht dann das dritte
ass und das mache ich ja hier und da
verstehe ich nicht
james völlig neues level kennengelernt
und auch für jay hat sich dank trägt
vieles verändert
sie half mir wieder zu mir zu finden
ich war verloren komplett zerstört von
der letzten scheidung ist super sie
lehrte mich geduld liebe machte wieder
einen positiven menschen aus mir
sie lehrte mich dass ich der bin der ich
bin ich möchte nur wieder zu mir finden
das stimmt sie macht mich schon
glücklich wenn ich an sie denke
dass du hier ist symbol für my name is
back der hand
ich vermute ja und das ist strafbar
das muss ich so liebe schließlich
angeboten
[Musik]
vielleicht läuft wohingegen neuseeland
oder der agent ich glaube ich einfach
sehr oft kultur lebt im hüte und
wirklich wichtig und man kommt morgen
[Musik]
im paradies fangt alltag aller
herrgottsfrühe njo
um halb sechs am morgen ist katja chance
sie muss geschaffen hast vier spielen
eigentlich nicht so klar und ehrlich wer
kann zieht obwohl mit dem hier spiele
was meistens aber er macht das am besten
macht
ich mache gern willi 100 prozent bin ich
vielleicht jetzt
wenn katja und ihre familie am morgen
aufständische ihre mutter rita schmidt
sven kubick und erst nur eine mit der
familie wäscht
louis ist nicht erlaubt
bei so viel größere zum nächsten denn
natürlich zu vergangen ist wie viele
eigentlich verpasst ist aber nicht viel
[Musik]
der alltag von raps fertigem egal ob
elia sieht er die maschine noch überall
über genios
ihr könnt ihr wie corona ja hier auch
[Musik]
und er hat einfach mal die fresse du
bist du kann oder ob unsere schweizer
kuh nachbar hoch erwartet und daher so
stefan schreiber und festgestellt kommen
nur eigentlich im trusted themen und so
und dann ist immer richtige mode
konversationen thema gefunden oder moz
katalog mit kaputten ist einfach süß ist
zum schwarzen geschrieben und haben
angefangen und dann hat das mit gemerkt
da ist interessiert klägliche
vorstellung
und dann hat er so virtuell funktioniert
wirklich gesehen und dann ist ja nicht
schweiz hat das sehr gut funktioniert
[Musik]
so rief die glücklichste david in der
schweiz ab und wurde und rumprobieren
zusetzt umgekehrt der thomas kleiber
park 10.7 sache und super den sbb
[Musik]
ja es ist schon vieles weg für die sache
habe ich so hat der familie oder
freunden teilen ist schert es ist schon
ziemlich ja es ist schon krass
wohnzimmertisch drei punkte vor auf ein
großvater seine stärke mit weg oder
großvater synthetische dazu dass ich mir
schon bewusst dass es ein abschied ist
ab 30
es ist mir jeweilig die sache mit dem
david zwei mal gemacht haben dann ist
jeweils ruhm und eine sehr komische
gedanken zieht um dort sein konnte die
schöne sie dann ist speziell aber so
strom ich selber wieder bis an das chaos
des spiels das wird
die erste schräg teens neues label
mögeldorf legen sie die letzte schritt
im alter levels in der braune tonne
im herbst 2008 10 startet thomas kleibl
sie zum letzten mal auf dem dach von wo
sie studieren oder zum teil am samstag
hoch haben aber anteil der noch in
unsere sind im lauf oder neue woche es
ist klar das blutbild haben auch und
lehrer und das ist im moment ohne musik
wenn ihre wir würden doch jetzt
abschiede thomas dass ich die neue lexus
anblick die bbc noch lange da du musst
wandern
[Musik]
sechsmal so wie sie immer von sehr
glücklich sie herr ist einfach mit
10.000 angeklagt
[Musik]
da wo es
wie wurde pressefreiheit monarchie zu
der natur und dj sid
[Musik]
das museum und verhaltenstherapeutin
wieder zueinander gefunden hat aber
nicht nur einen winkel vom schicksal
bucht sondern alte säcke vor der moderne
technik diese kollegen karl marx stadt
kommt und zwar eigentlich nicht nur
unbedingt dass der besuch für eine
bezirks und einfach bekanntschaft machen
muss schrieb ich hatte einen
dreitagebart da musst du nichts bezahlen
da kannst du dein profil erstellen
dein foto hochladen ich habe das einem
freitag gemacht und am sonntag haben wir
schon außerhalb der plattform
miteinander geschrieben
die spezielle frage was mache ich und
wir hatten vorher nie miteinander
gesprochen
dann stand ich am flughafen und dachte
wie auf dem foto das herunterkam
sie kam auf mich zu und ich stand nur da
dann habe ich ihren arm berührt und es
fühlte sich an wie ein elektrischer
schlag
wir schauten uns an und ich fragte hast
du das auch gespielt und sie sagte ja
und dann küsste ich sie auf den mund und
ich wusste das ist die wahrheit war
hatte ich ihr sagte ich werde dich
heiraten
natürlich glaubte sie mir das nicht
daran sich heiratete sie dann
und jetzt bin ich glücklich
[Musik]
ja ja ja ja
[Gelächter]
katja ist ökonomie der hsg studierten
sie schafft vollzieht wie die bank of
new zealand als beraterin für großkunden
wie schwierig oder wie einfach dass wir
da einfach aber ich glaube ich weniger
hat war so weit weg aber wenn jetzt sind
in wehr setzte sich nur einen job finden
oder man irgendwann ich halte er werde
mit den wieder schafft und ja nicht dass
da haben sie hätte sich im winter neben
den kv voll in die tat umsetzen werden
perfekt
[Musik]
daher glaubt noch leer bis diskutiere
ich lang zwölf profis sie jetzt im
wesentlichen husmann oder stay at home
at wie man so sagt
[Musik]
katja ist ein bisschen strenger also ich
mache und ich sind entspannter wir essen
eis und hängen ein bisschen nicht war
naja wir sagen mama nicht dass wir als
essen habe du verrät uns immer es ist
wichtig für sie da zu sein hier die
wichtigen sachen beizubringen
die ihr das gefühl von liebe und
sicherheit zu geben
ich glaube sie hat hier was sie braucht
sie nur dort familie von heute schuhe
[Musik]
ich mache die dinge gern schnell
ich mag keine unordnung sondern
sauberkeit hat er ist anders sie macht
sogar mehr durcheinander als maria da
braucht jemanden der auf die beiden
aufpasst vier ob ich familie zieht ihr
verbringt katja dj und maria häufig am
strand da wo sich am wohlsten fühlt
[Musik]
rasch das verantworten
einige ihn vom mehr weg ich nicht nur
europäische wirklichen lebensstil wie
nirgend wenden oder doch nicht wachsen
muss
drei worte oder irgendwas mach dich
wirklich mehr wind am bensberger
wegnehmen der 50 benannt ist man schnell
was immer kompromiss mache ich immer
bitte um korrektur wieder so weit weg
von der schweizer er wieder weg vom meer
locker kompromiss wo man auf jeden fall
egal aber vielleicht neben also
internationale partner auf zeit sind
vielleicht größte kompromiss habe ich es
einfach mit ihr eigentlich gern egal
um es wolle welche den hals mit der
person verstehen
irgendwie glaube ich halt der grund
wieso dass ich meine daten
appenzellerland mit dem thurgauer
dialekt rivale zu bilden na ja sogar
verschärft sich die täterinnen thurgauer
dialekt er verwies auf neuseeland will
bemerkt
der hexe oder am strand von mount
maunganui war dann schon andere grün die
vision eines lebens neuseeland und nicht
zwingend im kanton thurgau bett
verbringen
[Musik]
es ist wahnsinnig hübsch wahnsinnig
schön und ich behalte sympathisch ich
interesse und sportler und damals immer
nur sportlich und ja es ist daher
brauche aber von anfang an schwierig
sich an
zu dieser zeit wurde mit jeder skype at
anhänge anderen kontext carlo stefania
contact ukraine und in russland ist aber
die mit ihrer mit den katar open ist mir
klar dass die an der kontakt ab locker
und das mit dass sich das mit jeder
ernster vorgang der martin und lana
kennt sie vor sieben jahren per internet
erlebt und glied rücken
sieht er wohne 10 und thusis planer und
der ukraine
das geht jetzt in den ofen
der mag dänisch überzeugte vegetarier
plane sie sonst waren seine gurt und
natürlich wie immer wenn ein hund und
relativ holt sie mittags zeit und dann
nachher das ist dort eigentlich vor
allem sieht ihren gemeinsamen sohn de
león auf der welt ist weil man sich wie
etwa nah unter martin übers internet
kennen lernt rama show vor mehr streifen
rahmenbedingungen aufstecken und gewisse
wünsche anbringen
darum hält sich dir zwei auch schon
früher etwas thema hindus tust sie hätte
schon ein älterer sohn dann ist mir das
nicht erklären müssen sie beim kamera
fabrik sind denkt okay wenn sie
geschieden
ok und auch habe ja noch da müsste ich
entscheide zum geschenk also und anime
wunsch sich jetzt dienstag kann man wohl
dann mache ich sie natürlich relativ
habe ich nach dem sieg in der mini disco
nicht aus damit fehlen dem app store und
dann ist das natürlich schwierig sie
cool normale schwangerschaft lietzkow
und dann nimmt man halt noch ein
normales kind großziehen
was man schätzt dass ich das
global was louis
ich weiß jetzt wieder macht so plane ja
wir werden jetzt jede muss dann wieder
arbeiten gehen
was war ich muss arbeiten zuerst kannst
du ja wird - ist 22 jahre ist massimo
stufe les roses mexiko sogar die ukraine
näher an sie nachher ganz tolle system
um erleben mit dieser demokratie mit mit
diesem system wirtschaft verstehen was
mir auch sein und voll politiker ist
dies kein grund zum jammern so anders
leben und so wie sie ist klasse eines
air weg wählers luca ina i wanted to
leave you kripo live auf
[Musik]
familie spottet klebestift arminia das
ganze soziale karte tony hunt in der 20
wo sind sie und so nordbahnhof die
lampen stehen wie du
ich war erstaunt und fühlte mich sehr
geliebt
ich fragte mich ob ich dasselbe gemacht
hätte und ich bin nicht sicher ob ich
das damals gekonnt hätte
[Musik]
prägt hat zwei töchter
wir sind in der schweiz bleibe so
brigitta alles hinter sich hat und zum
gate usa
[Musik]
ich habe mit der sache nicht jeder
antrag muss toll und heißen etwas pompös
und meine ich habe einfach so speziell
sie wie sie richtig sie hat durch
kontinuität und nasse haar und alles vom
import und stellt mir in words und wir
haben das einfach mega kult planet und
weiß nicht das große strump dramen und
weiß nicht was auf mich dort auch
spontan kreta zusammen
das größte sich dass ich das mache
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aber die award.de dafür im exzess
native american sollten nicht weinen
aber ich habe geweint in diesem tag aus
lauter glück ich gebe es ungern zu aber
es stimmt ich war so glücklich
[Musik]
guten appetit
das feld
sie macht gern pläne ich schaue was
passiert die dinge ändert sich man kann
gar nicht klar
das ist wie das neuseeländische wetter
das wechselt auch alle fünf minuten
ich gehe es langsam an und verstehe gar
nicht warum sie immer so gestresst ist
es kommt immer alles gut und wenn nicht
dann findet sich eine lösung
man kann nicht so viele kleine machen im
leben
[Musik]
auckland
die größte stadt von neuseeland
da wohnten große drei majors innere
verwandtschaft
sie sind wichtig aber sie war gut ich
eigentlich dass wie die neuseeländische
ersatzmutter für katja der frau mit viel
familiensinn eine große herz und vier
schwiegertöchter ist gold wert
im nordostkongo bade
[Musik]
das mädchen am ball
der hätte schwierig
3 k nach dem motto familie von haitis
großmutter sind richtig die bezugsperson
wurde ich früher wie man am werkstor
befindlichen aria und präsenten hier
bevor sich verändert dass du vater
geworden das geschieht wohl allen aber
das ist eine gute veränderung
man hat eine neue sicht auf die dinge
man kann nicht nur auf sich selber
achten tun und lassen was man will
da gibt es jemand anderen zu hause das
ist gut
mit der bezwang ski wurden auch ein
vater gestorben ist es lieber
kurzfristig in dem moment hat ihn gut
zusieht wie ihre große familie kult ich
habe hart gearbeitet um in unsere
familie zu integrieren
wir wollten ihn unbedingt genau gleich
behandeln wie unsere anderen kinder
werden älter und katja zurück in die
schweiz gehen
nein das glaube ich leider nicht
neuseeland nicht verlassen
das hat mit seiner kindheit zu tun
ihm fällt die geborgenheit das wird wohl
sehr hart für katja blieb dies denkt man
man könne das leben zu zweit auf einer
einsamen insel verbringen aber mit den
jahren zeigt sich eine andere realität
[Musik]
naturwunder von rotorua [ __ ] chelsea
und heiße quellen und über allem ein
intensiver trug noch schweifen
[Musik]
also es ist aus unserer sicht ist es
bezirk für andere welt ist mussten die
stadt ist einfacher wurde aus der suppe
oder schwieriger auf das rechnet pesch
schwieriger ist eigentlich nur das für
mich auf jeden fall ist nur dass sich
mini familie und freunde vermisst aber
sollte bezirk zwischen dies jetzt hat
mit so viel schwierigkeiten weg legen
will mir vor anderen länder sind das ist
meter stand boni hat zwei familien in
ihre heimat nach einem affen in je
häufiger er stehen eigentlich also
definitiv mit den mittig stoppe ich ganz
plötzlich teuren unfall der den
schwarzen trolley wenn man so weit weg
ist und den ja ganz schwierigen zeiten
über leicht dass diese 23 ich das
wirklich den halt wenn über
so ein elternteil stirbt und innig wenn
wir jetzt noch mal auch nochmals
schwieriger den wir ja sicher den motor
wenn über die stadt oder geht sie dir
was du dem esstisch
sie macht überhaupt glaubt dass nach und
sie war oder ist nicht nur mit ihrer
halt will welt sehe ich wie haben sie
sie hätten wenig die hautpflege
objektive und wenn es nur immer maximal
zwei münchen wo sie sie hält am stück
und inhalt wieder für ganz lange nicht
den job schnell wieder region rom und
und mit gerät setzt mit dem awo es so
schnell warten so schnell vergisst und
fast alles klappt so hart für sie und
für mich
als kleiner sich miss heimatland ich bin
ein schweizer das kann man nicht ist
automatisch und alles ist so klar jetzt
zum beispiel auch selbstbewusst sie dann
gemeinsam am tisch er sprach und sprach
kein stück ist das land funktioniert du
hast du weißt die haut verteidigen immer
an den also nicht platzieren immer
landen du kannst spielregeln das alles
laufe doch und schiene frames haben wir
schwach und unsicher und verletzlich das
thomas kleiber wandert für sind made
david of canada der job bei meteo vom
schweizer fernsehen könnte womit und
sich vor allem verabschiedet
[Musik]
abschied von der ältere berührt und
seien offen
durfte thomas war das was ihm aber sehr
viel und wo es zum beispiel wohnen im
haus der schwiegereltern im ehemaligen
kinderzimmer von david bell mit deinen
neuen umständen recht kunden weiß es
aber noch nicht so recht
[Musik]
peter krah und neuseeland setzte ersten
blick im revier ferien muss bauminister
schweiz rund und dass mein vater husten
tisch
aber fügt ich wirklich ein entspannter
tag die bank fachfrau in torgau und die
surfer bickel händler mit mori wurzeln
freitag tochter maria gespielt aber
kommt es oft vor dass ihr tage für euch
allein nicht so oft bei der maria
eigentlich nehmen wir haben keine
verwandten da wo wir wohnen also ist sie
immer mit uns zusammen
es wäre natürlich schön wenn ab und zu
großeltern da wären die ziele süden
könnten
[Musik]
der onkel greg wo eine art ersatzvater
ich wieder zum fischen dürfen die
fischer begangen zunächst gleichwertig
näher oder wird nur wie hat man eher im
monat vor dem lande stabiles land das in
gold sich immer noch nicht obwohl ich
doch lieber nehme ich mir das mal sehen
[Musik]
in einem land wie der schweiz eine
schwierige vorstellung so viel in das
diskutieren wir gerade nicht für immer
aber für eine gewisse zeit
ich war in der schweiz ist schön da aber
für immer das kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen und dann wischt sie besuchen
eine welt rühmen dass sie für im moment
msi das wüste zurück neuseeland oder die
schweiz die frau wird sie wieder weg ins
leben lang begleiten
[Musik]
zum artikel und danke für den
kreisläufer der welt
werner jung
kann ja jeder sagen dass schweizer bin
ich das gefühl russland jetzt das recht
schnell falsch interpretiert
auto-schweiz millionen schweizer bank
gespielt
[Musik]
nein sie unter dem ihs sind eine ski und
sieht vier york führte die liebe täter
was für sie gerade bis zur gibt im
moment sind monterey im nächste gruppe
wurden 15 maxime ich nein sie hat mexiko
psychologie studiert dem es zur bank
layoffs matur gemacht und bis der beiden
essbar worden sind hat es peter bruch
spd
nein sie ein ort wo typisch für mexiko
und spricht sie haben sind dick und
macht mit dem hessischen fußball spielen
aber es ist nun mal wegen war allerdings
größer als die spieler damit sie die
heime kurzerhand zum beispiel dorf cola
oder putzmittel wo man die heimat kommen
brauchen völlig bin ich am besten
probiert oder so
von julia hatte demis bankbeamter anzug
und krawatte abgestreift hat sie einen
älteren trainings sie sind an die
rückseite und die schlossgut welt
entdecken
ich bin zudem zieht buch nur mumie
wahlkreis nach dem schulabschluss machen
und bin schon eineinhalb jahre unterwegs
da noch sie zurückstoßen wurde darja
klischina von mexiko auf der pazifischen
küste gar nichts extremen club sonst in
sexy dessous erlebt erklärte denise
gemüse krämpfe nennt sie erst gar nicht
um religiöse nur ihre telefonnummer
hätte können erobere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe so extreme abfuhr erteilt dass
das mein ego so geschadet hat dass ich
das einer definierten kleine hubräume
nachmittag ist sie dann zurück auf rang
drei was vor 20 uhr stunde vor dem feind
sind und haben ihre nachfolge als
muntere vor sitzungssaal sonst stunde
mit dem bus dann nicht jedes mal wenn
ich bin ja bis jetzt wieder so ich bin
und was mein gott dass ich ein
psychopath werdet mich vergewaltigen
oder sie sich das mega schlimm aber dank
dem song könnt huster und kurz zu farben
auf herzen ruft ver.di nancy und die
ganze familie gottes dass ich achte
halbjahr her und jetzt zudem ist nein
sie in hus fällen ältere
[Musik]
almost all die menschen die hitze mehr
stimmung aber schon nach fünf minuten
bin ich aus mexiko mehr umarmt und küsst
wurde als die dc-10 regal zu buche
für mich ist das der erste mexiko
besucht das mit der ganz und gar mit der
schönen aber schwer zurück sich zum volk
noch schwerere welle im hafen wo bist du
zuerst ist mir aufgefallen dass er
anders ist
ich habe sofort gewusst dass ihr ehemann
meiner tochter wird warum er hat mich
entzückt verzaubert ich liebe ihn wie
einen so dass die verbundenheit so
typisch hat will ich noch ein anderer
grund betrüger wurde denise vor fünf
jahres 2001 auf mexiko ist familie
gottes tief erschüttert derrick der
nutzer jährig brühe tor für den 1 hat
sich kurz vor ots leider knapp
[Musik]
anziehung der dort gehört warnecke sich
nach der planlose situation sie war
sprachlos crm systeme für rassen uhr cet
labern und aber nicht ob das land nehme
ich das dass wir irgendwann alle
zusammen
zusammen werden sie erfolg seiner
schönheit jetzt aber im letzten dreißig
sind gerade jetzt so die etwas stark wo
es passiert ist und ich glaube ich
eigentlich schön dass du jetzt da bist
das jeder sehen wie das ist ja noch lang
ist noch ein die fans taxen ein
lieblingsfach taxi tag der toten durch
die pressionen braucht aber zugleich
auch islamische und die lage wirklich
jeden tag als ob es dein letzter wäre
sydney platz okay jetzt so viel geld auf
die sieht das anders sie ganz genau
diese la reid will more voellig bornim
existiert oder
[Musik]
sid woran ich mich erinnere dass sich
bei unserem ersten treffen viel
gestresster und verkrampfter war als ich
es mir je vorgestellt hat und was ich
mich interessiert hat das herzschlag
das ist herr zu so schnell dass ich war
wie schnell sie ist herzschlag das ist
es wieder zeit dass da etwas sehr sehr
aufgeregt ist
[Musik]
metro -look thomas kleiber existiert
wenn nur zum david und seiner familie
ziert auf der berüchtigten lose winter
von beck und bewohner im untergeschoss
vom hof der schwiegereltern
[Musik]
es erinnert dass peet lehrt
wohnsituation von ra teenager liaison im
sous soul vom ältere hus natürlich werde
jetzt gleich berufen wie die high oder
dazu menschen ist gefühl das wird eine
schlacht
aber das ist natürlich schneller will
sich als sagen wir mal kaffee statur für
mini hobby star neu definieren und so
dass ich ja gastronomie schrank dass ich
so wie jetzt mit dem ich muss freundlich
alle diese lässt sich dann noch auf die
blöde sachen ruft neue jahr fangen aber
das ist aber zufrieden ist ich habe ich
bisher ab eigentlich hätte david und der
thomas vorjahr im kleinen rahmen welche
orte wo familie von dani hat andere
pläne
und es ist es richtig großes freistoß
wurde
[Musik]
als die zeremonie begann und wir mit der
ganzen familie reinkamen hätte ich mich
am liebsten in luft aufgelöst
mein mund war so trocken meine lippen
klebten an den zähnen so schnell fuhr
oder zwei mal eben aus binational facher
macht und dazu alles ins kanada hoch
zieht der vergleich schlecht licher
inzwischen seien verständlich das sind
sehr schöne erinnerungen
[Musik]
extremer druck mache generell hoch sieht
man muss sich das mal vorstellen da hat
der autos unterschiedlicher standen oder
wie viele denken
und nun spielt die familie
sie sind so sind so oft sechs sieben
großmutter die hat erst vor kurzem
erfahren dass ihre länder vorstellen
wieder die meisten würde der werden und
was sie gemacht hat sich auf mich zu und
mich zum ersten mal gesehen und einfach
verdrückt und seitenhalt du machst mir
da willkommen
[Musik]
grenzenlose liebe heißt viel aus und
fiel neueste zur bühne
endloses schneeschuh wie zum beispiel
wenn die der heimat so langsam die
ersten schneebälle mit
[Musik]
trainiert wird der besucher und das ist
schön weil man das gefühl hast dass du
etwas schief geht dann besteht auf dem
richtigen das macht schon automatisch
für leben musst du das automatisch
machen
das kostet überwindung
[Musik]
nein sie unter dem es für ihre tests
wünsche und vorgaben aber sie malt
bilder und verkauft die auf und er
produziert wien fürs internet eigentlich
ist ganz alleine für deine 21 ließ
klangkunstwerk weltruhm erntehelfer in
florenz und gelegenheitsarbeiter
hauptsache sie sind mit genannt für ihre
youtube wendt meint 3
neues video unterhalb von monterey
doch er fährt auch glücklich meine liebe
du hast mich nie fahren und mutter auch
nicht
ja das ist meine tiefe spuren wachsen
rückzug und
[Musik]
online-videos soziale medien bilanz
geschichte vom schrägen schweiz wo sich
sehr stehen mexikanerin und dennis land
verliert seine arbeit als youtube wie
zufällig mit selber gemachte videos
können freunden und familie die wähler
zeigen wo das sie gerade sind
[Musik]
ich habe mich seitdem in die hand und
dringlich überall wo ich weiß nicht was
sie später
[Musik]
mit dem veloster viele sinnvolle
ausgeflogen
touristen bringst du mich damals so
traurig dass ich sterben sagte ich mir
wenn du mir mein leben egal ist
du wirst mit dem velo losziehen dann
komme ich mit
egal was passiert
machen wir es
[Musik]
iris ziel vor alaska bis patagonien
fahre kilometer und alles mit dem was
gemeinsames großes abenteuer kunden weg
zum thron verarbeiten wo noch im tod von
bruder erneut sinn im leben finden
[Musik]
die liebe kämpfen
von gefahr zugfahrt hat sie gegen
abschluss wieder den text
hey ich mich dann schon am morgen was
ich super
[Musik]
das womit andere teile bauer sagt für
die höchste liegen
das leben sind die familie ganz konkret
zweimal in der woche brachte sie für
über 200 bedürftige im drucklosen von
monterey das richtige familie projekt
alle helfer mit wir dachten wenn wir den
anderen helfen geht es ihnen besser
aber in wirklichkeit geht es uns besser
wenn wir anderen helfen
[Musik]
monterey liegt im norden von mexiko und
nur zwei stunden vor der amerikanische
grenzen weg statt mit über vier
millionen
finanziell geht es der familie gut drauf
an den hals und weinte
henzler und tod von eric embryo für den
einzig inzwischen tradition wurde oder
ganze familie den vorarbeiter von einem
schweren schicksalsschlag hilft und das
ist es warum es grad ist nach geht als
es sogar die polizei junge gesprochen
[Musik]
es ist schön die friedliche atmosphäre
da und ich fühle dass dynamik balsam ist
für zählen vor allem also ja natürlich
war auf der internetseite besonders
forderung kam wurden also experte darauf
filme quiz den händen über über die
ukrainische und russische frauen einig
geworden so und das ist dann so mehrheit
ich habe es nämlich so dass das die
frauen auch er damit wirksamer sind als
schweizer frauen waren die deutschen
frauen das frauen mitteleuropa karriere
anstreben und die frau hat im in der
ukraine dass die bereits in zum trauma
sie
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor weihnachten will anna
ihre mutter erschoss drei wochen besucht
[Musik]
ich hatte mir anfangs sorgen gemacht
dass unsere unterschiedlichen charaktere
erneut aufeinander bringen könnten wir
sind halt wie wildschweine
wir sind beide im jahr der schweiz
geboren mutter ist ein leittier und ich
bin ein leicht hier und wir sehen nicht
nach aber jetzt für mehr frieden
geschlossen
diese gibt es verschiedene drogen mafia
car crashes super league kennt das nicht
da wird nichts genial und sehr schönsten
hier schnell
[Musik]
hier ist die wohnung also das heißt es
der ausblick von draußen das ist liegt
das ist dann das ist wichtig ja das ist
ein kanal eigentlich ja wird wetten
haben geraten
da ist alles es war immer mein traum
nach amerika zu fliegen
wir hatten martins bildungsurlaub schon
vor anderthalb jahren geplant oder war
es vor zwei jahren
[Gelächter]
ich lebe schon so lange mit martin dass
ich immer glaube er könne russisch als
ob wir schon 50 und nicht erst sechs
jahre zusammen wären
ich freue mich sehr im frühling nach
miami zu reisen
ich bin stolz auf meinen mann dass er
uns als familie dieser reise an diesem
schönen ort ermöglicht nach 220 jahren
der schule lindsays grade martin
bildungsurlaub machen
ich suche sprachaufenthalt in den usa
alle sie spürt es fehlt nur noch visum
für planer fans verteilt
[Musik]
für mich ist ein segen ihn kennengelernt
zu haben
er hat mir eine neue welt eröffnet einen
kleinen sozialen kreis gesprengt ich
glaubte dies kam und sagte schau mal das
alles gibt es
ich war gott sehr dankbar alles was ich
mir gewünscht habe traf ein
ich war sehr verliebt und jetzt kann ich
meinen weg gehen und er seinen denn wir
sind beide frei legt den blick wieder
familie gottes
[Musik]
reviers mitte mai eine messe
wo werde ich euch in fünf jahren treffen
ich würde gerne in mexiko bleiben aber
um kinder und ein haus zu haben will mir
der jury von mexiko lieben authentische
rot und reiseportale front schweiz ev
die schweiz also dass ich einfach
sensationell wenn du darauf august wird
dann last minute dann kommt vielleicht
einmal als du musst einer geldbuße
überhaupt grund oder zwischen winterthur
und zürich wird der stadt winterthur und
der staat syrien und erfahrungsraum
stichmann vier stunden lang kaputt dann
muss der finder waren der busfahrer und
jetzt auf google risiko die homepage und
dann muss stets ab zählt im bus kapelle
der automaten das ist nicht einfach
[Musik]
kanada schlafen ja morgen früher das
wohnquartier am stadtrand gehweg fahren
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
minute sieht der thomas kley problem
ihrem radio sind die wetterprognose
gemacht hat jetzt lebt er bis ihm am
david und bis eine schwägerin und das
alles macht thomas aus liebe zu dir ja
genau
für dich sogar schnee im untergeschoss
ist es aufs neue die heil und thomas
klein
das ist mal an das genre sicherte sich
vor
die fahrbahn erhält also historisch ist
zu hell lauter
nach dem hauptgang stars sind da die
einzige verein steht jetzt noch so viel
schnee gefallen
das leben ich weiß noch dass ich das
natürlich das wäre zu starr meter schnee
es schaut jetzt wirklich viel besser aus
hier mehr unser ziel ist jetzt unser
ziel ja dass ich genau hatte david
gemacht und ich in der schweiz daher sei
das ende der schweiz haben
der wert dieses mal wechselt die
grundlage jeder integration ist die
sprache wie du deine umfeld schafft dein
humor wie du dich eingibst wie du
kontakt zu den leuten aufnimmt ich finde
auf die wort nicht was ich kann nicht
spielen mit der sprache vom dienst will
ich trage was er schon so eine
diskussion habe ich mal so mit
medizinischer home ist sicher schon mal
verbieten
und dann war da nichts spruchreif ist
ironisch zu machen da musste muss
präzise sprache und dann wäre das gar
nämlich am inn humor und überbringen und
wie sie sich in luftige familie sie
lachen viel und ich einfach mit dazu
beitragen dass ich bin mir echt
langweilig trachten fluss
und neu besonderes frustrieren jetzt im
winter mit dem vielen schnee ist thomas
als passionierter velofahrer oft
schließen ohne eigenes auto wir
schrieben ruf andrea zum 9
und so ist der ex metro mag so zieht
schnee schufa im hauptfach rasch fertig
du mich dass es nur winter schnittstelle
start mit der mia und piste alles
geschmolzen ist david schaffte
unterdessen im kreis ihrer familie in
der hoch wie das der thomas noch keinen
job hat sieht er entspannt wenn er jetzt
noch nicht arbeiten will verstehe ich
dass er wird bestimmt eines tages etwas
finden dass er wirklich gerne machen
wir müssen das beide ganz entspannt
nehmen
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich dass ich ihn
unterstützen kann
es ist eine schöne gelegenheit ihm etwas
davon zurückzugeben was er mir gegeben
hat aber das muss auch so funktioniert
plan macht aber da jetzt fühle ich dass
ich stan vor ihrer jugend wo sie noch
änderung im system von kommunismus oft
wachsen ist der leaf in die rezession
breit gemacht die hände plant oder zeuge
aber total darunter trübt organischen
scheiße ist dann hätten sie ihrem plan
festhalten obwohl schiffbruch erlitten
und dass das ist klar sie sich zwar
lange hat sie in dem zu stehen klebt und
das projekt bilder der entrada morgen
hält martin und lana aber alles minutiös
planen
sie sind unterwegs in us-botschaft
bayern für planer als ukraine
riemenschneider somit usa reisen
[Musik]
das b b 246 plastik falls
dahinter applaus das ist alles bewusst
und mit dem minister vertreten
ich habe gesagt das ist
3 aber drei wichtige und zwei andere
dokumente alles perfekt klappt worin er
hätte
[Musik]
naja
prof
[Musik]
okay was jack bauer in wiesa securlog
gut
[Musik]
nervöser und warum die etwas wissen mit
hätten
[Musik]
ok
hürden überwinden und neues anpacken
das weiß zimmer nächste ziel vor martin
und lana heißt
[Musik]
im alltag ich nehme viel übrig von der
indianische kultur früheren umso
liebevoller pflege mitglieder von der
stein die traditionen was noch gibt
[Musik]
findet statt
ingo holland 70 menschen mit
indianischen wurzeln von zwei
verschiedenen stellen
ich bin jedes mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn brigit mit mehr tanzt wird mein
herz leicht ist überkommt mich auch eine
wehmut denn die frauen unseres stammes
tanzen nicht mehr korrigiert ist zwar
nicht native american aber sie ist meine
seelenverwandte
die leute akzeptieren dass das ist das
gute
wenn du die frau findest mit der du
zusammen leben willst
sie ist die meine
wir glauben dass wir vorher zusammen
waren und für immer zusammen sein werden
wenn im nächsten leben vielleicht nicht
in dieser form aber zusammen wir sind
einander vertraut wir gehören zusammen
[Musik]
die bärin wobei der hund so ein akku
ausgetauscht und felix gottwald zurück
diesmal aber mit mir wünsche deiner
beide blumes bestellen
[Musik]
besucher der schweiz im davis in ihre
models biersdorf sie hat sich damit
abfinden dass sie ihren sohn nur seite
wurde dem sv gut sei jahres in rucksack
packt und auf weltreise gegangen ist und
dann noch immer länger und länger und
dann hat es auch nicht natürlich danach
verstummt das jetzt irgendwie einem
republikaner und überall korrigiert aber
es ist doch so gerne hat alles mit ihren
social media manager postens ganze
wirklich großen moment im leben wie sie
[Musik]
ja
wir haben selbst
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich glaube zu sehen
jetzt rufen
[Musik]
und so groß ist gratulierte nancy und
babys und sind jetzt gespannt wo sie
slammer aus familie hinführt mexiko
betriebs oder viel ist noch ganz neu und
anders steht die heißen die beiden
sowieso auf der ganzen welt
[Musik]
warum hätte so viele killervideos so
dass man unter 8 milliarden menschen
der richtige verein selber findet per
floß wundern
und wenn der 1 die otto die einzig auch
anderen handy für die welt wohnt ein
buch gott normal leisten damit es happy
end gibt es trost bleibt wohl für immer
unbeantwortet was ist ein klinisch rein
dazu bringt alles hinter sich zu und
jahr zeige so wird aus der thomas und
david genau an dem ort gemacht
die webseite durch linie vom winde
verweht war schon seine restrukturierung
und es bleibt ein das sind das für drei
jahre
das darf man den verstand sagt ein
zauberer ist es wirklich extrem gut
gemacht aber seine familie und mini
familie verbindet und sich tragen sie
weg ist und das hin und her und die zum
teil monatelang transmitter und wie man
mit dem umgang sind ich würde mir dass
er seine gemacht was die kräfte baske
wir sind sehr stolz es gab schöne
augenblicke aber auch schwieriger im
april ich will nicht verheimlichen dass
es auch diese schwierigen situationen
gab dass wir es geschafft haben das
macht mich sehr stolz
das sind einfach super und der ganzen
werde dich immer und immer wieder
heiraten
[Musik]
david ist was hältst du dir für eure
gemeinsame zukunft
ich wünsche mir dass wir uns nicht zu
viele sorgen machen dass uns die zukunft
nicht belastet dass wir zusammenbleiben
und dass es uns gut geht egal wo wir
lesen werden so wie es richtig ist was
ich mir wünsche ist dass ich es schaffe
da im gepäck sachen platz finden wo wir
wirklich die high bin dass ich
geschichte an und das ist dass das
tatsächlich für die schweiz vor allem
nach gebäck und nach kanada
ja
[Musik]
ich habe gesagt dass ich mich nicht
aufopfern musste wenn du glaubst dass es
auf ordnung ist dann ist es keine liebe
ist das gesagte flickr sara lee begibst
du automatisch gerade noch die kurve
gekriegt
ich sage jeden tag ich liebe dich jeden
morgen
ich berühre sie immer wieder so bleiben
wir verbunden
wir beenden sogar gegenseitig unsere ich
liebe ihn so wie er ist ist gutmütig
großzügig und dirigent
sascha kohlmann insulin sprechen werde
auf meinem inneren sind nach jener sich
glücklich schätzen über ihre einem
russisch könnt ihr die kleinen tasse
dieser denke mehr an das mache
und dann wurde film schon fast fertig
ist erreichte ist vom anderen ende der
welt neue wunderbare nachricht als
neuseeland gibt es nachwuchs katja und
lg erwartet als geschwister die für dich
linie nachher
der region
ja
hin und weg mein blut der manager keine
gleichwohl zeigen dass wir die grenze
und hindernisse überwinden seien
wirklich vorbei aber ihre
liebesgeschichte die
[Musik]
hin und her ich präsentiert wurde von dr
oetker